krakatoa tubes are a very famous
experiment and one of the simplest
experiments that you can do but you
should never try and do it at home
we're going to demonstrate mechanical
explosive now as your some of you you
shy from doing anyways by putting a heat
source under a sealed glass vessel with
some liquid in it but we're going to do
that it consists of sealing some water
into a glass tube by sealing I mean
clear closing the tube so the water
can't get out
that's water in there it's just colored
blue over the dye so you can see it and
a couple of mills in a thin-walled last
two which is sealed the water boils
generates a high pressure of steam and
as the temperature goes up more and more
water evaporates and the pressure goes
up and up and then suddenly I think that
was fairly satisfying at a good
demonstration of a mechanical explosion
well the glass collapses in an explosion
I reckon that it probably takes less
than a thousandth of a second so
probably between one frame and the next
on your camera so it's very quick
probably what happens is that the glass
gives way in a particular point and the
crack then spreads and cracks travel
through glass with the speed of sound so
it's really very rapidly
it's called Krakatoa after the famous
volcano that blew up in 1883 the reason
that Krakatau is applied to these tubes
is because of the theory or one of the
theories why this volcano exploded you
have to imagine an island with a volcano
like a mountain with which had been
erupting for some time and then there
was a big eruption and little while
later matter of hours the whole mountain
was blown apart by a massive explosion
the theory was that the lava came out of
the top of the volcano and left a large
hole which was red-hot or even hotter
than that and seawater rushed in
seawater at the normal sort of
temperature 20 degrees centigrade in the
tropics
and as this amount of water went in it
was thought perhaps up to a cubic
kilometer that's a very large amount of
water it vaporized because of the high
temperature of the rocks and the steam
expanded and blew apart the mountain
just like our steam blew apart our
little glass tube and the violence of
the explosion was such that it caused
the huge tsunami which was big enough
that the tsunami was still a few inches
high in the English Channel right on the
other side of the world tens of
thousands of miles away from Indonesia
but the most striking effect around the
worlds with the sunsets that were caused
by the clouds of ash that went up into
the upper atmosphere and there were
brilliant sunsets for several years
afterwards
now with our glass tube we have these
shields around it so the glass when it
blows out is contained but it almost
completely disappears
you don't give get a slightly broken
tube it effectively has been vaporized
orde-lees pulverized into tiny shards of
glass
and Krakatoa was similar but the dust
went up into the atmosphere